this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your money your work your
relationships your life pretty much
anything and everything i'm john delonay
your host today joined by my co-host and
good friend best-selling author ken
coleman and we're taking your calls on
just about everything your money
questions what do you do next your
relationship your work hey and if you
are in a toxic work environment you're
trying to figure out this madness that's
going on with the work environment and
relationships trying to figure out give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to mario
brothers in grand rapids what's up mario
hi how are you what's up man i'm doing
great how are you
i'm doing well thank you for asking um i
was just calling to uh see how you
at the dave ramsey solutions would work
in moving or excuse me how you guys
would work um
moving from a different state into the
baby steps is it a good idea uh i guess
depending on a financial situation or is
that something that's not recommended at
all
tell me a little bit more
i don't i'm not starting to understand
your question you're you're allowed to
move of course um
you're a grown up you can do whatever
you want but um tell me a little bit
more right
no um i guess uh because you know my
wife and i we are just trying to work
out uh getting out of debt we um besides
the house we only have about uh sixteen
thousand dollars left um in debt and um
we will just be moving from um
uh to a more expensive state so and i
was just saying if um i guess is that
something that
um
that you guys
get that kind of question a lot or if
it's not necessarily recommended where
usually the cost of living in this state
is a lot more expensive well why are we
moving forget the cost of of of uh
living in one state forget the baby
steps for just a moment why are you
moving
uh well my wife um has a potential uh
has a job opportunity there for a little
bit more as far as money-wise but
like i said the um you know kind of
going back to the cost of living sure
there's a lot higher does it further her
career long term is this the last step
for her or does she feel like this is
one of the right steps to get where she
ultimately wants to go
uh she does feel like that this is a
potential to um eventually being
a manager yes right which means even
more money correct
correct so mario you don't want to do
this why not
um i it's not that i don't um i just um
you know my cousin has uh introduced me
to uh the plan not too long ago this
past summer he was actually just on your
show this past summer uh at the
debt-free screen and you know i guess i
was just kind of considering that i
really want to get to where him and his
family are so um i was just like i don't
know if that throws a wrench into it um
you know
it could be possible have you run the
numbers have you guys run the numbers as
best as you can on what utilities are
going to be so when you talk about cost
living you're scared and it's it's a
very legitimate fear mario that all of a
sudden
if we make this move and the cost of
living is higher it's going to take us
longer to get out of debt that's what i
think i'm hearing is that correct
right yeah all right so have you come up
with no problem so
have we run the numbers have we because
you can do this you can actually go okay
here's what property taxes are so if we
determine where we're going to live john
you know we can kind of go all right
here's what property taxes are in the
state here are the local property taxes
here's what uh utilities cost in this
area you can actually do a really good
cost of living analysis and so when you
get and again i'm not saying it's going
to be super specific but you can get
pretty darn close and then look at your
current budget in grand rapids michigan
and look at this new location we go okay
now we have a real idea i think it's so
scary right now mario because you don't
have
numbers to plug in and i think one of
the greatest fears in the world is the
unknown is that sound about right
that sounds about right right then so
you're you've got 16 grand left to go
you're crushing it you guys got momentum
yes or no
yes all right then plug the numbers in
your wife's gonna get an increase in
salary we get that all right talk to
your accountant get a good idea what the
take home might be with this new salary
and begin to look at all those other
indicators john i think when he does
that i think then it's managing that
emotion that's right so mario i've done
this twice my wife and i have where we
took
major um household income pay cuts to go
to a job a town a city a job that was
right for all of us and that meant
multiple things it was better for our
family it was better for me
professionally it was better in some
cases and sometimes worse for her
professionally she made a concession in
one and then she won and the next one
but every time it has paid off
financially in the long run because all
the other things were right and it was a
good good professional fit and so i
think the key here is making this move
without taking on any debt
if you have to borrow money to make this
move and you're gonna go back 10 grand
in the hole because of x and what
man you don't have the money to move
you see what i'm saying
so make this transition do what ken said
when it comes to
making the budget for what this is going
to look like this is about numbers this
is not about can i leave the state or
not that's right and mario i know you're
new to the plan so here's what i want to
encourage you with something very
practical here
people cash flow things all the time in
their debt journey we hear debt free
screamers come up and they go well we
paid off this amount of debt but we also
cash flowed getting a new washer dryer
and so this is just like that there is a
cost to moving now hopefully your wife
has she gotten an offer for a moving
bonus to go towards moving expenses
it's uh not necessarily a bonus but just
a bump in salary and paying for the move
okay so here's my point
so whatever the cost of the move is
right
packers movers whatever there is a cost
of moving
if you have to
cash flow that while working through the
baby steps that's fine
so you're not doing anything out of the
out of the norm so back to that initial
question yes it's okay to move if it's
to a better life you and your wife agree
that this is the right move for us the
baby steps don't necessarily have to
stop but if you have to pause for one
month of the move that's fine we pick
back up we're out of debt your wife's
got this massive opportunity in front of
her that she's going to climb a ladder
that's better for everybody nothing to
be scared of here but go get some
answers plug it into your budget
and keep walking out the baby steps so
as we head into the break you're kin i
think two important principles emerge
use real data when you got it that's
right we spend a lot of time in our
heads oh yeah that's true having
imaginary conversations and what about
this what about this that a simple
spreadsheet can often solve for us it's
true is this a good move for us and the
second thing is man
use
use the baby steps as a path to walk on
and don't ever forget that you can pause
the baby steps stack up cash if you're
having a baby if you've got to go to
surgery if you have to move you just got
fired life happens along the way a kid
all of a sudden is like hey i'm i'm
dropping out of college i'm coming
things happen
the baby step two just says don't take
on any more dead i'm just running like
crazy to get out of here but oh baby up
surgery up cancer up mom's gonna move
with us great that's life don't take on
any more debt so i want mario y'all save
up a bunch of cash brother
get this move done y'all are going to
move you're going to love it
congratulations by the way very exciting
time celebrate with your wife tonight
stuff a little bit of that fear buy her
some flowers take her to a nice steak
dinner or cook it yourself no let's go
out
triple
825-5225 we'll be right back
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john deloney joined by ken
coleman we're taking your calls on money
on life on work all of it let's go to
mark in phoenix what's up brother mark
hey guys thanks for taking my call hey i
got a about to receive a commission
check of about a hundred grand
whoa don't roll through that so quickly
how about mark
are you selling uh uh chips for cars no
i think he's selling space shuttles what
are you selling man
well it's it's it's been it was a lot of
work right so you know
you know we want to try and celebrate it
but at the same time we don't want to
kind of mess anything up with it so
we're trying to just figure out kind of
what to do with it and where to put it
and all that good stuff all right so uh
where what's your debt situation
so we're we've been debt-free for about
three years maybe except for the
uh for the house excellent uh so
no debt to speak of how much do you owe
on the house
uh 319.
okay what's it worth
uh probably about uh 475 maybe all right
cool and so you're walking it out you're
you're off you're fully funding your
retirement baby step four correct
yeah so that's kind of what we're trying
to figure out is okay so we've got this
money and it's going to come in probably
at one time so trying to figure out okay
so we need to we need to fulfill the the
three to six months right emergency fund
right but then where does it go after
that
oh okay so you don't have a fully funded
emergency fund yet
no no no not fully funded okay so let's
just run the numbers
okay so what do you think your tax hit's
gonna be on that have you figured that
out
i think it's probably going to be about
25 to 30 percent
okay so you just take that number and so
let's just do easy math because i i have
to take my shoes off to count that high
john uh so
let's take 70 000 that's my point so
take 70 and you go okay what do we need
to put into baby step three the
emergency fund three to six months
expenses how much would we have to put
in there to get that to where you want
it
uh probably 25. okay so now we're
dealing with 45 000 correct
so we got 45k
so have you uh so now you would uh you'd
look at baby step five if you've got
kids you got kids
yes
okay so i guess you hit one
eight-year-old one eight-year-old okay
so certainly getting that uh college you
know esa
29 even just a little bit we'd love for
you to get with one of our smart vester
pros this is where i want you to talk to
them about what that would look like but
i'd certainly look at a contribution
there yeah even if it's small put a
little bit in to get it started as the
principle right yeah because now all of
a sudden you've fast-forwarded uh into
baby step five and then monthly you're
gonna start taking 15 of your income
right take home and putting that to
retirement so now you're working on baby
step five and six
you know and so you know i i i'd look at
a nice chunk uh on the house if we were
to put the rest here's
tell me if you're struggling with this
mark i would celebrate a little bit that
was my only thing yes take a little bit
here and let's enjoy some of it yes
there's this feeling and it's happened
to me you get a check you did really
well
and a thing happened and we have this
imaginary ticker run in the back of our
mind which is if i could just get a
hundred thousand dollar check
and then when we do what ken and ken
just did it's kind of deflating oh
then 30 30 000 goes to the government
and then uh this goes to the emergency
fund and you end up with like five grand
to play with
and that kind of sucks right
let's be honest
you would think that a hundred thousand
dollar check solves all of our problems
and it just doesn't it doesn't i'm
buying an island that's right and we're
not no so here's the thing
feel good celebrate with it a little bit
go do something have a fun weekend but
you're gonna just keep track in these
same baby step principles right in the
same way as though you got this over the
course of a year and you're going to
take 15 of them put in here you're going
to give some of it away you're going to
put some of it into even if it's 500
bucks or 5 000 bucks into your kid's uh
college you're going to start crushing
this house yeah you're going to start
crushing this house and let's get the
house over let's have an even better
year this year let's get 125 thousand
dollar commission check that that's what
i wanted to do a quick follow-up on yeah
all right so mark
um
what are the chances that you're gonna
get another big old commission check
like that in the near future now that
you know what it's like to scale that
mountain be
don't be overly humble don't be cautious
what are the real chances that you're
gonna hit another one of these big boys
i think i think it's realistic that you
could do one a year all right then
so think of the progress that you just
made with this breakdown we just walked
you through and go hey i've done it
before i can do it again and next time i
fully fund the kids college and then i
pay off more of the house and i have no
house payment now all of a sudden the
next time i get to check now we're
buying an island now we buy the island
hey what's your salary mark what's your
what's your annual salary
uh
combined yeah probably 140 to 160. my
mine's probably about a 100 100 110 okay
so you got a 140 150 and then this
commission check comes in on top of that
yeah
so i think you could sit down with the
math my brother once you have no you
have your emergency fund full
you owe nobody anything except for this
house i think you can have your house
paid off in two years yeah no it's
stupid two years man you owe nobody
anything crazy fun
and so how so how do you divvy up then
the 401ks and all that stuff in the raw
that's kind of that's a smart investor
pro so we want you to go interview
minimum three smart investor pros in the
phoenix area okay and you wanna and dave
has said this a million times so i'm
just repeating dave's advice you want to
meet with several because you want to
figure out the one that's the best fit
for you personally they need to feel
like a coach heart of the coach is the
attribute that dave has driven in our
smart investor pros and that team that
works with these fine women and men
secondly
not only do they have a heart of a coach
are they explaining it well to you to
where you understand they're not just
telling you what to do but you go oh i
get it
and so sit down with them on the 529
or the esa for your child because you
got some money to get that thing started
and then talk to them about the 15 in
retirement now you're in baby step four
the minute we do this so now we get to
our budget okay and he's going to give
you or she will give you a plan to
invest the way that dave teaches that's
why we want you to meet with a
smartvestor pro go to
ramseysolutions.com
and search smart investor pro and
there's multiple in phoenix that'll help
you out it's real important to go and
this is a sales pitch i hear
so let me just call that out
it's who i go to it's who you go i mean
you use these folks yeah here's why you
knock on the door of a random old
financial planner they have a hundred
thousand dollar check their eyes start
rolling around their head they see
dollar sign dollar sign dollar sign they
don't see what's in the best interest of
you
and smart investor pro knows our plan
you know hey the best thing for you long
term which ends up being the best thing
for me long term is to get this house
paid off and then we're going to make
some real money on the back end it's
awesome congratulations moses in dallas
what's up moses
hello what's up man
how are you doing outstanding how are
you
i'm doing well so what's up how can we
help
i'm 20 years old
i'm enrolled in a trade school currently
employed at a at a dealership right now
i'm in the parks department but they're
they plan on moving me into the shop as
a technician
when i am about a month away from
graduation
i am married and my wife is currently
unemployed okay right now i'm sitting at
20 an hour
right i make about 45 hours
in a week that's about five hours of
overtime making around 36 a year i have
50
50 grand in debt
20 of it is a car loan which i'm about
to get it down to 15
15 because i got some i got some money
in savings
i was wanting to know
what are my options i know one option is
sell the car basically pay off
the loan plus some of this out of pocket
out out-of-pocket payments that have to
do for the school what's your car worth
i
recently looked it up the minimum is 15
the most i can get is around 20. and you
owe what on it
15. like 15 flats i'd sell it get
yourself a 3 000 4 000 car because you
know how to fix that daggum thing
brother i'd sell that i could sell that
car asap running out of time let me tell
you moses i heard that my wife is not
working she can work if she can work she
needs to go to work you're working 45
hours
you can bust it put another 10 or 15
hours in this season to get out of debt
until you get that higher paying job
this is about income i think you're
walking out the baby steps keep doing it
follow the plan way to go i think the
wife's got to bring in some income and
you got to bring in more income and now
we fast forward this process
825-5225 we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hey ken um we're getting closer and
closer i got a new book coming out own
your past change your future we're
getting here man launch day is april
19th and it's still in pre-sale
and i am the baby's ready pretty dude
i'm pretty jazzed yeah that's pretty
jazzed uh it's for everyone
a single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind 25 year old
who just wants to make friends how do i
get reconnected a mom who wants to
connect with the kids better people
coming out of abusive relations every
body and the reason is folks
as i interrupt the author
everybody has a past
everybody that's right everybody now
some past are nastier and harder than
others but everybody has a pass and
turns out it shapes us in the now but
more importantly
unfortunately has a tremendous amount of
undue hold on our future that's right
and i think that's why this book is for
everybody
because everybody you don't get to walk
on the earth and go wow i got nothing in
my past that affects me the way i look
at the future you don't get to say that
it's all her fault all of it
my boss and the boss i had before that
the boss before that it's all their
fault right so hey um here's a cool
thing let's do this so
this is some inside baseball but um
kelly's running the show today and she's
encouraged us to give away things today
on today's show we love to give away
stuff because most of the time we're
giving away dave's stuff so i want to
give away something of yours can i give
away something of yours i feel like
that's fair what do you want to do okay
so
if you pre-order the book today i don't
even know folks this is very exciting if
you pre-order the book today today for
20 bucks by the way it's going to come
with the free month of therapy from
betterhelp it's going to come with the
the audiobook i feel like it's like for
19.95 and you get right it kind of is
actually priced down oh that's right
like we're on it's four a.m in the
morning we're trying to sell you a
carpet cleaner right but um you read the
book to people you don't know tell
people now that that one month of better
help is incredible but then they get the
audiobook right and they get the ebook
plus plus let's do this so one of the
things when people close the book and
not everybody in fact most won't i'm not
closing you close the book and you say
today's gonna be the day
like i i agree that i'm worth being well
i'm worth i'm worth more of my marriage
i don't want my heart to beat out of my
chest when my husband drives up the
driveway anymore i want to not walk past
my kid's bedroom and they can't look at
me i'm ready to make some changes
some of you are going to pick up a phone
and call betterhelp and say i'm going to
talk to a counselor
others are going to say
i am worth not living in my job like i
have been.
and i don't know what to do so can we do
this can i give away if you order today
and this is just me making this up here
so it's very exciting if you do it today
can we give away your career assessment
let's do it so that's a 30 assessment
that's 20 minutes
and you're going to get unbelievable
clarity get a professional purpose
statement that's the get clear
assessment that john has just decided
and you're giving up your cut on this
you have to go out the door hey john
it's okay my kids need shoes but it's
gonna be all right
uh thirty dollars uh that is a product
uh in the store at ramseysolutions.com
so here's what you got to do so now i'll
tell you what i'll agree to give away a
product i get no cut which is fine okay
i'll eat a little less this month john
because that's how much i love you
that's how much i believe in the book
own your past change your future and i
really do this is great stuff you got to
read it all right so here's the deal you
go to
ramsaysolutions.com
and you order john's book today it's in
the it's prominent you can't miss it
ramsay solutions.com in the store
and click on own your pass change your
future buy it today you get all those
other goodies and then you're also going
to use the word
ken
kelly how about that for a coach can you
do that yeah we're going to do
ramseysolutions.com you're in the store
promo code ken the marketing team will
figure it out promo code can and you get
the uh all the goodies of owning your
past change your future all three
formats of one month of counseling cool
and you get to get clear career
assessment and if you're clear give it
to somebody who isn't that's fantastic
thanks for that of course i'm very
excited about it it's john deloading.com
repositions.com
ken no don't go to slash ken yeah oh in
the in the uh ramsay solutions.com you
go to the store you put it in the promo
store the promo code is ken
i know kelly i'm i'm trying to hold his
hand
it's it's just just you know let's go to
kerry in st louis what's up gary how we
doing
hey guys how are you outstanding how are
you
pretty good so i'm 29 years old i've
worked in sales for nine years currently
working in outside sales with a coffee
company
i'm just really over sales and unsure
what i want to do i do love the product
i sell i really enjoy coffee and i like
the company a lot i'm just not feeling
fulfilled i am a really good top
performer typically ten percent and i do
have like these dream jobs often that
i'll make up in my head but i do change
them that's okay i did take the
clear career assessment my top talents
are communication justice and execution
and my top passions are promoting
performing and solving hold on slow down
slow down slow down slow down go back to
talents i can't write that fast you've
been drinking your coffee all day yeah
and i just sprained my wrists trying to
keep up with you okay go ahead
communication top talents communication
justice and execution justice and
execution okay and then top passions
this is work she loves promoting was one
what to the other two
performing and solving and caffeine
and then your top missional result
results you want to contribute to the
world through work what was that
i didn't have those write down i would
have to look back at those okay my guess
is
um
are you let me ask you this
do you like solving
because uh
solving was one of your
top three passes do you like solving
people problems listen to the to the
options here we got multiple choice
process problems okay
idea problems
or thing problems do you understand
those four
things would be like working on engines
you understand what i'm saying
okay i would definitely see idea
idea problems like hands down okay hands
down i like this now for the audience
tell us those top three ideas because
you said i get all these dream job ideas
and then i change my mind give me the
last three that were in your head don't
don't try to explain them just tell me
what they are
i'm opening my own coffee shop
the second one i did go to esthetician
school so i have my esthetician license
so those are really the two that i've
enjoyed or you know kind of thought
about interesting
um
it's really interesting that you when
you took your get clear career
assessment did you feel like it nailed
you and if it didn't that's fine because
it's not about my process it's all about
you and answering the questions did you
feel like it nailed you
i really did yeah when i read it i was
like this is me okay so here's what's
interesting when i hear those ideas we
always want to take those ideas when
they go okay do you have the talent to
pull those things off communication
justice and execution very quick for the
audience uh that's it's not used to this
language from the get clear career
assessment communication we obviously
know what that means
justice means you have a talent for
identifying right and wrong you see
injustice where others do not see it you
act on it that's what the idea of
justice is it's a high level of of
of what's right and what's wrong and
then executions just get her done as
larry the cable guy likes to say right
get her done okay so what's interesting
is esthetician feels right for that
coffee shop if you're running the shop
day in and day out creating a space for
people to come and have coffee and
communicate um and you are promoting
that service or promoting
that product you get really juiced about
it which is why you're really good in
sales
you enjoy promoting something you
believe in true or false
oh absolutely okay so here's what i want
you to do i want you to take that
purpose statement that you got in your
get clear assessment and i want you to
take these ideas coffee shop esthetician
there's been more and i want you to look
up a job description of those types of
jobs or careers and i want to just look
it up online so that we turn our brain
off
stop overthinking i want you to look at
the job description
and then i want you to look at your
purpose statement side by side and what
you're going to see is is the purpose
statement from the get clear assessment
is like a it's like an overlay that lays
over and you go wait a second
does this be an esthetician allow me to
use
what i do best my talent
to do work i love to produce results
that matter to me do you see how that's
going to work
you start testing it out and then we go
look into it what's it going to take to
get qualified and then
how much is that going to cost how long
is it going to take
that simple process will build a bridge
for you to the future that you want keep
pressing in
and you're going to figure it out and
switch to decaf we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this week we announced that our building
wealth live event is coming to both
vegas and orlando baby
look for john and i at the crafts table
it's gonna be great we're gonna
i was gonna say we're gonna take down
vic i'm gonna be in bed by 9 30. oh of
course i'm not very cool everybody
building wealth is a hot topic right now
everyone and their brother has an
opinion on how to do it whether it's
crypto single stocks drawing cute
pictures um on our computers and selling
them for trillions of dollars zero down
real estate and then inflation is
everybody freaking out join me dave
ramsey rachel cruz george campbell and
k.c ken coleman as we unpack these hot
topics
plus ken and i are jazzed we're both
going to lead a free bonus session
before the main event
we'll talk through and and john and i
are working on being able to bring a
tiger to that
pre-session
so why would you come early john and i
on stage with a tiger one of us is gonna
get eaten
i just have to outrun you man
yeah that's worth the ticket price in
and of itself we'll talk through how to
balance your work in relationships so
you can live a richer more fulfilled
life isn't that what we're all looking
for so get ready vegas
man
we're coming to you thursday may 5th
orlando we're coming your way on
thursday may 19th if you're not in these
cities it's okay we'll announce more
dates this fall tickets for building
wealth start at just 25 bucks or you can
get a four pack for only 60
incredible deal don't wait the tickets
are blown out the door go to
ramseysolutions.com
i realize the tiger is ridiculous but
what about a boa would you wear a pink
furry boa i i that's that's part of my
normal speaking oh it is outfit anyway
it might it's like more of a
mic yeah it's a costume that's a thing
all right yeah so you'll if you if you
want to see if john's going to do it you
got to come to vegas 100 chance let's go
to laura in st louis what's up laura
hey what's up
we're just rocking on man making this up
as we go how about you
i'm doing great i just had a question so
how do i know if my debt payoff date is
what it should be
so our debt payoff date is currently
june 26 june 2026 and we make about 86
000 a year
so yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
pause okay
i don't make 86 000 a year we make 71
000 or 70 100 a month and our debt is
about 86 000. sorry
okay so how did you come up with june
2026 as your payoff date what
information led you to get to that date
as the finisher ramsey solutions
actually so we're currently in financial
peace so i use the every dollar right
that happened i put it on our date so
it's kind of a loaded question
well there's a question behind the quest
there is yeah and that question is you
can't
you can barely fathom being married in
2026 to this guy much less
being on a debt-free journey is that
fair
i mean he's probably the best person
i've ever met so no no i'm messing with
you about him but this feels like a long
long time doesn't it
it's nice it does it just yeah it's
insane
what do y'all do for a living
so i work at a university and my husband
is actually a youth in children's pastor
awesome but so your date laura is based
on a budget yes or no
yeah so what would cost the date to go
further into 2026 maybe let's say fall
what would cause that to happen
i mean if we weren't diligent and what
we're planning to do okay good answer
which isn't going to happen which isn't
going to happen and let's throw one more
out just for logic here uh you maybe had
to cash flow something so we did press
pause at some point because life happens
those are your three options a b and c
right
okay so we know two of those aren't
going to happen you're not going to stop
being diligent and you're not going to
take on debt so life could happen so
that might change the date now let's
let's do the reverse what would cause
that date of june 2026 to move up to
january 2026. what would cause that
um raises yeah uh getting second jobs
yeah but i don't think that that's
realistic we have three young children
under four but that's fine so getting to
the heart of your question
you know what were you afraid of when
you called in today and you say hey it
seems far away is it how do i know if
it's accurate you just answered your own
question that's how you know if my date
is accurate by the way
it's going to move from time to time
but we see historically john that people
pay it off faster than they originally
project hey laura can i press in on you
for a minute
yeah
um one of the things we often see when
we lay the plan out is somebody says
yeah i see that butt
and you have a yeah but
which it sounds like
you have a picture in your head of what
mom and dad and family and three kids
all look like
and that is not gonna be able to move in
your mind that's the way that is and so
what we're gonna have to do is work
around that variable
and working around that variable has
ended us up in 2026.
and so you're gonna have to make a
decision can you not poison the home you
and your husband and being frustrated
and bitter and kicking the couch because
y'all can't go on vacation and not going
out to eat until 2026 or
can you all look each other in the eye
and say we're going to shift the picture
of what this looks like for 18 months
and we're going to call aunt susie to
come watch them and she's going to be
all great anyway and it's going to be
weird and they're going to have to eat
beanie weenies or whatever it's going to
happen
and i'm going to get a job you're
getting a second job
and then you're going to mow lawns on
the weekend and for 18 months we're
going to live maniacally and we're going
to live outside of our picture so that
in 2024 and a half this thing's done
you see what i'm saying you've boxed
yourself into a corner and you're gonna
make yourself bonkers because you've
made it either or either everything goes
away or what i'm saying is what if you
did it for just a minute for just a
season and you change everything yeah
you know what i mean
yeah yeah that's the that's what's got
to shake and that's what's got to change
okay i want to i challenge you here's my
dare to you laura
is to
sit down with your husband and say what
if we did things a little bit different
for 18 months intensity
what would that look like
right that would be different ken have
you had a time in your life when you
just
grind your ground yourself down and if
for a goal right to get something i'll
never forget it it's it's one of the
funny stories dave ramsey got uh all
fired up in a staff meeting several
years ago because he was trying to beat
another friend of his company and
participation of employees in the
nashville marathon half marathon so dave
and another friend were like all right
let's see who can get the most it's all
for charity employees okay yeah so the
company would pay you're running your
race fee or something like it was
something about charity
i've slept since then
he decides to challenge me in front of
the entire staff because i said it
privately said coleman you gonna run i
go no
that's for people that are nuts people
that have deep therapy problems they
don't want to go see a counselor so they
go run
all right hours a week yeah yeah so it's
a long story short he guilted me
live in a staff meeting in front
everybody said coleman hasn't signed up
yet ramsey personality doesn't want to
contribute to i mean literally went
after me it was funny yeah so of course
i in the moment i caved immediately
regretted it but i had 12 weeks to get
ready for the half marathon 12 weeks and
any runner out there knows that's crazy
and if you've ever seen the office
episode
where they had the great race
yeah so you were andy yeah so i called
up my good buddy bill who you know yeah
who had done triathlons and everything
and i said there's only one way
that i do what's necessary to not
basically walk this thing
and it's you coaching me because i knew
he'd beat me up and i knew he'd hold me
accountable and i knew i'd do it
and he did it and the training regimen
six days a week brutal it was
awful
it was just shy of medieval
torture
for me who doesn't love to run i love to
play sports i just don't like to run but
uh i remember going you know what two
miles a day and i had a goal to break
two hours was it was a stretch goal yeah
and we went after it hard and i remember
buckling down going this is about the
goal and i'm going to intense
intense focus
on achieving the goal and you know what
i didn't think i could do it i remember
when he emailed me the first time the
plan john and i was reading it i was
like this is week one
and then i scrolled down into week five
and six and all this kind of stuff and i
remember telling stacey there's no
way i finished this training
and i'm gonna be okay with being
humiliated by dave ramsey the rest of my
life but i did it but but but i will say
credit to a great coach i'll say credit
to you because you changed the picture
for a season i did decide to accomplish
a goal i decided you're gonna have to be
intense so then i'll let go
and that's what you prescribed to her
everybody just do the hard thing for a
short season yeah but it pays off in the
long run yeah it's good it's an hour in
the books we'll be right back on the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions in nashville tennessee this is
the ramsey show where america hangs out
to have a conversation about your money
your relationships your work
pretty much anything and everything
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john deloney joined here by ken
coleman and we're taking your calls on
life so give us a shout triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to ella in
los angeles california what's up ella
hi there how are you doing
um it's not too good to be a hundred
percent honest oh thank you so much for
being honest what's up
um
so my husband and i have been married
for four years and he has a son from a
previous marriage and it's a really bad
um it was a bad divorce
my step sent almost 10 and they're still
in a custody battle and i found out
about my husband
well we lived out of state and we moved
three years ago to be closer to
his son and that was a horrible decision
because we don't have any family but my
husband has
racked up about two hundred thousand
dollars in debt to his attorney
and he's on a payment plan of twelve
thousand dollars a month
oh all
a surprise i had no idea i
knew something was up so i went into his
email which i shouldn't have done
and i saw the bill and i
like i felt like i was going to be sick
and i told him this morning i wanted a
divorce i mean we've just been fighting
all the time over this for the past
three years while he's been fighting for
custody and he told me that he's not
going to stop until he gets full custody
and i had no idea he was filing for full
custody and i don't want full custody of
the son because i'm a stay-at-home mom
and i would have to be the one to
deal with him and he has some um
developmental issues i don't know if i'm
allowed to say what they are but he he
has a lot of behavioral problems and i
i'm not i can't take that on and i i
don't know what to do i just feel like
crying almost yeah first one yes that's
that's the appropriate response you're
in the middle of a hurricane right now
it's a lot
um crying is a is it is a
smart good healthy thing to do right now
um
you've got a lot that you just put out
there what can we help you with today
well
i'm
almost to the point where i want to just
you know i mean it's really hard to do
the debt snowball when he keeps i mean
this attorney is like 600 an hour some
high-profile attorney in like santa
monica
i don't know how we do the debt snowball
when he keeps adding more money and i
also don't want to pay for
this because i i feel like as a spouse
he should have come to me and said hey
i'm thinking about getting full custody
what do you think
so listen
you
we call it financial infidelity here
we call it betrayal everywhere we call
it dishonesty we call it lying whatever
words you want to call it
but your
your guts all over your kitchen floor
that feeling is correct
part of you was stolen part of your
relationship was stolen from you
and if i'm him
i don't get i don't get the betrayal
part i don't get the dishonesty part i
get the i'll go to the ends of the earth
for my son i get that but that's a
conversation you have with your wife
right especially to the tune of two
hundred thousand dollars and it just i
mean it's illogical you can't pay that
and so
your feelings are justified in good what
i don't want you doing in the midst of
this pain is making
lobbying grenades back that doesn't help
anybody
i'd love for you to get with some people
in your life that you can circle up with
and can help you walk through this piece
by piece because there's lots of pieces
this isn't the moment for baby steps
this is the moment for
your marriages i mean you you basically
told him this morning you want a divorce
and i understand why you would say that
no there's no judgment here but did you
mean it or did you just throw that out
there
um well i mean honestly these past three
years i've probably threatened divorce
honestly
it's like every other week i'm
threatening divorce so ella let's stop
that let's stop that yeah okay let's
don't threaten divorce anymore
either
i've reached the end of what i'm going
to tolerate when it comes to the
deception and getting dragged through
the mud and you living a dual life and
your dishonesty all that i'm done with
that
or i'm all in on this
but we have to be all in on this to get
like you got one or two options
threatening divorce
i mean it's just it's a weak childish
play don't do that don't weaponize
relationships and make that but say i'm
in or i'm out and then once you say i'm
out then it becomes a business
transaction
and then we're gonna go down that road
together well i
ella john's right i we certainly can
help anybody get out of debt but you
guys aren't even
we got to reconcile some huge issues
here and the one is
he's not going to stop fighting for a
son at least that's his position up to
this point right so we've got to get
clear on that because you're going i
don't want to parent this kid
at the house forget the money piece yeah
the money piece is exorbitant and it's
probably going to keep growing so john's
absolutely right this is a relationship
call right now
because then we decide
what do we do with the money i'm just
curious how much money does he make
well he's a real well he's in the army
reserves um and he's a real estate agent
so these last two years have been really
really good money but he's only sold one
house this month because of everything
going up so
um last year he made almost four hundred
thousand dollars um and we have nothing
to show for that right are you currently
paying the twelve thousand dollars in
the uh
legal fees are you is he paying on that
or is that just racking up
um he came with a credit card so i think
it's just fracking out oh
we have separate finances so i don't i
don't know and i'm gonna stay at home
mom so he doesn't tell me
financially i have no idea hey alex let
me know anything ella are you safe
um
like he's not
um i'm sorry hell are you safe
he's not physically abusive but it's
like he doesn't we have an age gap and
it's like he treats me like on his child
and um
all my family wants me to leave him
but i don't want to do that to my kids
because i promised myself i wouldn't let
my kids go through my childhood um but
it's i'm 24 and he's 49 we're almost 49.
okay
so i i am never ever going to tell and
if somebody's
in the midst of um
unsafe abuse i'm going to tell somebody
get out okay
i'm not going to tell you
to pull the trigger here i don't know
necessarily that i agree i i think that
there's harder things going on in your
home than you're saying out loud is that
fair
yes that is okay
i want you to call somebody today
and if you've got family members who say
we love you and we're seeing something
that you're not seeing what you're
hanging on to is a picture of a fantasy
that you created because you don't want
your kids to experience what you did
which is beautiful and great and good
i'm glad you did that the reality is
your picture has changed
full stop
and now the question is are you going to
hang on to that old picture and drown
and bring them with you or are you going
to create something new yeah asap and
most of us when we're drowning we cannot
get out by ourselves we need other
people and you've got people around you
saying hey we're going to help we're
going to help we're going to help please
lean on them
okay and i would just say ella you
cannot fix this marriage on your own
absolutely your husband is you can't put
that glass back together on your own i
think it's uh it's not a threat but i
think uh
i think we got to see if he wants this
marriage i can tell you right now he
doesn't right he wants a daughter and
that's not you yeah it's time for you to
reach out to your family and y'all start
making a game plan of what comes next
and if you are being hurt
get
out you're worth more we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to christopher in spokane
washington what's up christopher
[Music]
hey um a quick question i guess i'm
gonna try to make it quick uh so i'm a
local truck driver
and work uh at nighttime delivering
pizzas but i have an opportunity to
leave washington state go to alaska work
for uh summer it's seasonal work
how to be dropping my local
truck driving job
to go to alaska is it a fishing job
uh no okay i'd have buddies
industry
for the cruise industry
yeah okay cool
what's that what's the payoff if i go to
alaska what happens
so if i go to alaska i can pay off all
my debt
by october and have ten thousand dollars
when i come home
how old are you
34.
are you married
no
no kids
no tips but
you were saying and we cut you off
but finish the sentence
but um i would be losing my health
benefits and everything
and i would be pretty much jobless and
homeless when i get done okay first of
all all right that's a little dramatic
okay
christopher come on you scorched her and
i'm gonna be homeless and nobody will
love me and my grandma's gonna take her
socks back
well wait a second you're gonna be free
you're going to have ten thousand
dollars going towards your emergency
fund which is baby step three what is
three to six months based on your
current income
uh current income yeah what's three to
six months expenses
probably eight thousand okay wait a
second so now we come back from alaska
we have no debt
we have a fully funded let's call it
three months is that based on three
months i'm guessing the eight thousand
and i'd probably use that money
you what
i would use that money
when i come back to get ahold no you
would not no you're being melodramatic
i'm gonna show you how
so stay with me in my narrative we'll
get to your narrative if you don't like
my narrative
all right our pets pets are falling off
come on yeah i mean man the sky is
falling okay so listen you come back and
you've got 8 000 in your emergency fund
you got 2 000 left over so we know
you're not going to be under a bridge
starving you're going to at least have
plenty of lifetime supply of ramen
noodles for 2 000 bucks okay so here's
my point you also were in a high demand
job as a truck driver true or false
true
you also will have communication
instruments otherwise known as phone and
email while you're in alaska true or
false or pigeon in small piece of paper
fair i mean for heaven's sakes you gotta
hire a dog to deliver a message all
right so so you can you can communicate
back in your area and go hey and it's
possible that your your current employer
may need you back because you're not a
jerk and you do a good job is that true
or false
that could be true all right dude come
on so what's that what's up what what's
the hang up okay yeah
you sound like someone's forcing you to
do this
no i'm just wondering if it's worth
doing
because i'll be dropping
where i here i pay rent and everything
else and food and everything but in
alaska i won't be paying that
right so you're pocketing even more
money so if you don't go how long until
you pay your debt off that's the
question
i would say 18 months all right then so
do you want to pay it off faster or in
18 months
faster then go to alaska and eat some
great salmon
and then don't cut your arm off because
you don't have any health insurance yeah
i mean you're okay you could self-fund
your any health needs so man you're on a
cruise ship what if what if i have
really a really bad gallbladder
and well wait a second remove do you
have a bad gallbladder or a history of
gallbladder
okay then maybe not having insurance is
not the plan for you
so then don't do it we're not telling
you to be risky but let's play this out
though
um
are you talking with a doctor now are
you in care right now to where they're
going it could we may have to remove
your gallbladder in the next year two
years i mean what tell us what the
doctors are telling you
uh they just uh they told me that it
could go it could not go if you eat
healthy then
you could potentially have a your same
gallbladder
or the gallbladder forever if you just
eat healthy well you could be talking
about me right now and i've never been
diagnosed with any gallbladder issues
that i'm aware of knock on wood i mean i
hope it stays but here's the deal what
would a gallbladder surgery
cost you without without insurance
maybe 10 000. all right then so you
start weighing
do i want to go to alaska or not i mean
the thing is is that there's a small
chance that that could happen i guess
but uh at that point you go okay
well could i afford it
and you're also christopher
man you're talking a few months to pay
this off right as you say october versus
a year and a half
i think this is a different conversation
if it's six years or yeah that's true
eight months then i would tell you dude
you roll the dice you live once do the
right now man it's six more half dozen
another i agree if you're worried about
the the risk of the gallbladder stuff
and being saddled with a ten thousand
dollar bill
uh then then don't do it
i would go i personally would i'd eat
really good i would well i don't know
man i may blow my gallbladder up on a
cruise not me no if i knew my
gallbladder might blow up i'm gonna go
i'm going to the google and i'm going
what's the good gallbladder stuff but
they have those cheesecake buffets well
the buffets are an issue i agree
oh my god bladder wouldn't make it let's
go to brendan in chicago what's up
brendan
hey can you hear me of course man what's
up
hey how's it going outstanding how can
we help
so i'm calling because i just have a uh
i guess a full rounded question i'm
basically so i'm about 30 years old
and i'm contemplating whether i need to
rent
more
or finally settle down and buy a home
and then even furthermore what state
that home is in
i'm living in chicago now
i'm from suburban philadelphia
and um basically i have some family
issues
in philadelphia and have a lucrative
well what i think is lucrative job in
chicago
and i'm just wondering do i buy a home
outside of philadelphia or do i stay in
chicago
where i've been doing well i've been in
chicago about eight years
and i have a remote position now uh at a
market research company and i'm
wondering do i finally head home be
closer to my family
or
stay in chicago and kind of be this
shadow figure where i kind of help
support
my family remote
so i kind of that's what i'm weighing
right now
so there's a lot to this question um
we'll dig into a little bit here but i'm
going to hold you over the break because
there's a lot we can pull a pull from
this call um real quick i think just get
out of the gate can you afford to buy a
house right now you have
10 to 20 down fully funded emergency
fund
so right now i make 90 grand a year and
i have about 32 grand in the bank
um i got approved for a loan
that would kind of land my mortgage
around 1500 1400 a month
so here's here's the price
a little above that okay so
that's a fallacy
i'm more concerned with if you if that
1400 bucks that so that is below your 25
take-home pay um do you have any other
debt
no okay so you're you're debt-free right
what's the lucrative position in
philadelphia going to pay you
no he's lucrative in chicago it's not
there's philadelphia where he's born and
raised
sorry i misunderstood i apologize so
going back to philadelphia we'd have to
try to find a job that pays you
what you're making now
exactly and one of the you know drivers
of me staying in chicago is i have this
maybe it's a fallacy belief that
marketing jobs are easier to find in
chicago
versus philadelphia that is a foundation
basically
yeah i
i
last time i lived in philadelphia was
you know seven eight years ago when i
was struggling to find work
i went out kind of
got my life together sobered up
found work you know got my life
straightened out and i'm doing well all
right brandon hold on hang on hang on
let's i'm gonna stop you right here
because you're gonna come back we're
gonna put you on hold and we're gonna
bring you back after the break
um and so remember where we stopped here
you got sober you're doing well and then
there's a dot dot dot we'll be right
back okay brother
stay tuned everybody this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsay to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm john delonie
joined by ken coleman so we're going to
go back to chicago to speak to our
friend brendan
brendan you called to talk about
potentially transitioning from a new
life you've created in chicago where
you're making great money you're in a
career you love
where you found sobriety where you found
just uh you've created a new world over
the last eight to ten years
and you're considering moving back to
philadelphia where your family lives
where your
home was
and so we've talked a little bit about
the money um it sounds off the top of
our heads just doing off top of our head
math that you can buy a house you could
afford a house
um
here's my big question brother
like
why do you feel this pool to go back to
philadelphia
so i feel the pull because when i left i
was struggling you know i was drinking a
lot my mental health was
horrible i was in a bad position
um but i'm one of six kids
and uh
from
my dad remarried but uh you know
basically all six of us have our issues
and i left
got it together
um and always thought you know maybe
leaving my siblings back you know around
home they'd eventually just grow up
you know five to ten years goes by i i
get it together and actually just like
this past year one of my step siblings
hung herself
and i look at the remaining siblings
there isn't a dime between any of them
and they haven't progressed the way
i worry about that i just worry about
them
and
my dad's getting old now he's not
working anymore he lost his job
and i don't know how to help
i want to help financially that's my
main
push to further my career
but i feel
chicago is this
goldmine of like successful businesses
and marketing opportunities like
you know it it seems like things have
been doing well for me
selfishly in chicago yeah and then
everything is kind of right where it was
in silly and actually i'm i'm with my
girlfriend now and i just went back
toward looked at homes and
you know all these roads they kind of
made me queasy flashbacks there you go
so i'm like let me hop in here and i'm
gonna turn over to ken to talk about the
career aspect but
yeah mental health
and relational health all those
challenges
are almost
not always
often often often
environmental they're contextual
and you were able to
summon the strength the courage whether
somebody went with you or that you saw a
pinhole of the light somewhere way down
the road and you got out
and getting out let you breathe new air
and walk on new grass and be around new
people and try new things and stand up a
little bit taller
my fear is you're going to go home
and you're going to go back to an
environment that made you sick in the
first place
and in fact you've said the words it's
like time stood still everybody's
exactly where they were except my dad's
older now
and so there's nothing about re-entering
that war zone for you that makes sense
and i also get the idea that you found
your way
you swam through a swamp to get to a
boat and you're watching your brothers
and sisters drown and you can't you
can't stand that either so you're stuck
is that am i on the right path
uh yeah i mean essentially yeah uh you
know
but i worry
if this continues
you know what if this whole the incident
of this past year you know what if
that's not the end like what if that's
not the straw that broke the camel's
back what if it just gets worse and then
i'm 800 miles away
you know can i ask you a hard hard
question you know transfer that money
and stuff no no no no no no no no i want
you know brendan this isn't about money
brother
i'm gonna ask you a hard question okay
what are you gonna do
fast forward do you buy a house in
philadelphia am i even equipped to like
start coaching them the answer is no the
answer is no brendan here's here's two
things i want to set you free on number
one
you cannot fix
these problems would you agree with that
you don't have the power to fix all of
these problems would you agree with that
oh 100
i mean i'm not a psychologist yeah i
know but here's the deal it's all said
and done no you're not you're not no
you're not but here's the incredible
second question
all i'm saying is i'm not equipped there
you go i get it good good so the answer
is yes
second question yeah can you be
influential
in the lives of some of those family
members that is true there we go but
here's the other thing and i'll give it
back to john who can explain why i'm
asking these questions i just know what
i'm supposed to ask that's great here's
the thing
brendan you cannot be influential if you
are broken
and you've gotten yourself healthy
you you have recovered you are getting
healthier and stronger every day making
good money potential to make more money
you have the opportunity because of your
healthiness
to be a greater influence on your family
in chicago in the life that you're in
now that's what i think take yourself
back brandon when you were drinking
if someone just threw ten thousand
dollars at you would that have solved
any of your problems
no i would have drank it away you know a
few weeks that's right so you don't owe
them any money either you got to be
smart for you so here's what i would
love to do i it sounds to me
like you've got stability and health as
can he eloquently said he's more i look
with me you've got stability you've got
community you've got a girlfriend you've
got life here
from this place
you can
anchor in and then you've got a place
where you can say hey brothers and
sisters yes if you need three months to
get your feet underneath you i have a
bedroom that's right and here's the
rules of my bedroom there was no drugs
here there's no whatever here there's
food and there is an opportunity to go
apply for jobs and you can provide a
platform for them to go
to go get healthy you cannot make them
get healthy and there is no deeper pain
than watching people you love decide i
don't want to be healthy
but going i mean
going back into the sewer with them
brother
there's six of them five of them you're
gonna drown
and it's not even their fault man
do you hear what we're saying
yeah but it and you're you're voicing
like my
better judgment and what i want to do
it's just why does my platform that can
my platform be like a hundred miles away
instead of 800 or like something that
they can drive
absolutely all right yes okay
what we're not saying that chicago is
the only place you can be healthy what
we're saying is
don't sacrifice the gains that you've
made the health and the stability that
you have built for yourself don't
sacrifice it because you feel bad
let me tell you this i think you need to
be a lighthouse not an ambulance and so
if you want to be a lighthouse 100 miles
away great but what has to be true for
that to be true brendan you got to go
get a really great marketing job in
delaware or and i don't know that area
of super well but you can get a a a
great marketing job in pittsburgh or
what but the point is is that john
pointed out beautifully that the streets
of philadelphia are great for rocky
they're not great for you right can i
bring in yeah i consider myself
relatively stable which is a you know
that's hard to say out loud but pretty
good
did you know my wife she can tell what
generation of friend i'm talking to on
the phone wow
by the language i use wow
and i roll back into 30 years ago when i
talked to the boys i grew up with on the
same street i love them to death
they're my brothers
we've bled together we've laughed
together we've snuck out we've done
crazy things together
and i start swearing like an
eleven-year-old third grader
i i it just it becomes the la and i'm
well brother
and you are too yeah but our homes it's
just a part of it and i have to really
be conscious when i talk to my friends
and say no no i'm a different guy now
this is who i am
and i that pull brother you're not there
you're just driving on the road you feel
in your stomach that's your body saying
not here not here
hear me say this you can only be well
i mean you can only help your brothers
and sisters yeah if you're well be a
lighthouse that's it that's it that's it
and i also want to say this i'm so
grateful for your heart yes what a stunt
absolute great heart
coming up next john's gonna break down
the potty mouth of an 11 year old third
grader because the audience wants to
know i didn't know that they cussed like
sailors but you apparently said so so we
got to figure that out i'll fix that
11 year old third grader
i stepped in it we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show all right so
that last segment i said that when i was
an 11 year old third grader i swore too
much
so what's factually true you swore too
much or you weren't an 11 year old were
you 11 in the third grade i was not 11
in the third grade i have an 11 year old
sixth grader right yeah and i just
whiffed that's fine it was funny
it was funny this is life people
understand that you're live and
sometimes your your brain gets going a
little too fast
and your mouth can't catch up yeah that
was my that was the case when i was a
regular eight or nine year old third
grader right i did swear way too much
did you oh man stand by me came out man
oh greatest movie ever great movie did
teach a generation of kids to swear
there's no question right yeah yeah and
the major league came out to say yeah it
was just a movies after movies man
i'm just a product of
entertainment i'm gonna blame them let's
go to emily in vancouver what is up
emily
hey john and ken how are you for taking
my call sure what's up
good um i actually have a career dilemma
um i currently am debating if i should
go to graduate school for physical
therapy
and end up being 150 to 200 000
in debt
with a starting salary of around 75 000.
yeah that sounds like a great idea no
you should not no
or what's the ore
or if i should find a new career path
okay well
you've either ordered yourself yeah i
don't know if that's even the right
choice
but let me ask this
couple questions walk you through this
why physical therapy why do you want to
do physical therapy give me the why
i really love it it's something that
i've worked really hard to get into
into this school
um what do you love about physical
therapy describe what you love about
that work i want you to pick yourself
working with a patient and you're
walking them through it what what gives
you that juice what is it about that um
i love the personal relationships that
you get to build with your patients good
and
um helping them like rehabilitate
okay and so you've worked really go
ahead keep going and
and
probably just um
the fact that it is like a really good
career and it does provide like that job
security right but i can tell you this
if you're a hundred fifty thousand to
two hundred thousand dollars in debt
seventy five thousand dollars is going
to feel like seven dollars and fifty
cents an hour that's what's gonna feel
like
emily is not worth that i'll free you
from this i've sat with
doctors
of physical therapy who owe their souls
and student loans and they make 75 000 a
year
it is not it's not worth it so now let's
talk about what what can you do physical
therapy can you do that training for way
less or is that the price everywhere you
go and i ask that because i'm ignorant
of what it cost to get trained to be a
physical therapist
it doesn't cost that we're that much
everywhere but you have to get into the
program and it's like a year-long
process that doesn't matter
that should not deter you nope 12 months
of waiting or 24 months of waiting to do
this work that's going to be there and
to be able to cash flow it so give me
the uh lowest price out there in the
united states lowest price to become a
physical therapist the training
oh i'd say maybe like
60 to 80 000. okay
and and now let's pause on physical
therapy
you said or should i do another career
i'm curious what the other option was in
your mind
that's the problem i don't have another
option yet okay so let me let me take
you down a path do you remember just
moments ago you described very
beautifully you gave me three
descriptions of why you like physical
therapy
you remember that you remember defining
it for me
all right let me ask you this have you
ever written those reasons down
and written them down so you could see
them and then have you looked into other
jobs and careers that would allow you to
do that kind of work does not have to be
in a moment of physical therapy where
i'm helping someone who broke their
thumb learn how to get full range of
motion again i had to do that one time
broke my thumb got a scar right here
tore the ligament and went through
physical therapy i've done it
that person helped me regain told i get
that outside of that context what you
described is the work you love where
else could you do that kind of work
have you have you examined that
i have not no and that's your homework
assignment and here's why
number one you can save up the money and
cash flow your way
through a sixty thousand dollar program
you can do that
it's going to take time and that sucks
john it sucks to wait worse nobody wants
to wait if i said to you emily are you
willing to do whatever it takes to be a
physical therapist what would you say
i would say maybe
the reason the reason why is because
i'm it's a three-year program i'm
already 24.
by the time i graduate i'm gonna be
close to 28 like i want a family dude
well listen
listen i love that but you're assuming
that you can't have a family while you
pursue
what you want to do you've got this
narrative that is completely false i'm
glad you acknowledged that
but my gosh 28 you're talking to a dude
who turns 48 this year spare me the i'm
gonna be 28 dude comment i'm not having
it today because i'm on your team emily
all right now let's keep going here
here's what i was getting at
most people say yes to that i'm willing
to do whatever it takes what we as
humans me included john included what we
aren't willing to do
is to wait as long as it takes
so we got to look at i got some very
clear goals i want to be a mama or i
want to be married whatever your family
goals are those are equally as important
as your
work desires more so
so we go okay can i have it all i think
the answer is unequivocally yes emily
but i do know this you cannot have it
all at the same time would you agree
with that
yep all right that's time to be a big
girl
now part of being a big girl is going
what else could i do
besides being a physical therapist it
wouldn't cost me 60. for instance
um
what other type of work could you be
helping people with their physical
development and thus their emotional and
maybe mental health
by guiding them
like a physical therapist would give me
one just off the top of your head
because you're a smart lady what's
another possible career forget about
what you know and don't know but where
you could do
similar work but it's not physical
therapy give me one idea
personal trainer boom
i'm not saying that's your thing i'm
saying your homework assignment is to
begin to explore and see what and i want
you here's your first homework
assignment i want you to write down to
the best of your memory those three
reasons why you are intrigued or you
love the idea of physical therapy
because see that speaks to your soul i
don't care about the career path
i don't care about the title of the job
i care are you doing work that you love
and you see some values connected to it
i want you to write that down then i
want you to begin to look okay physical
trainer i mean personal trainer okay
what else give me one more john you can
pipe in if you want give me one more
idea that is in that same lane if you
will of the work of physical therapist
give me another idea
athletic training athletic trainer okay
personal trainer athletic trainer sure
working with a team right you know of
volleyball players or football players
or baseball players or whatever and you
are
individually working and connecting with
these people to help them to advance so
i want you to begin to see what the
world looks like um and then i also want
you i'm giving her lots of homework john
i also want you to start researching
schools and then what would it take for
you to save up 60 000
to get licensed or certified
to be a physical therapist and who cares
if it's three years from now
so there's two important takeaways
one is an experience that my wife had
she was talking to two really smart
folks and they they were in their 30 i
think they were 35 and they were talking
about you know we wish we'd gone to med
school and husband was like yeah wish we
go to med school we should have man but
if we went now we'd be 42. my wife
because she's wise she said
the question is not should we have gone
to medical medical school is the
question is you're both going to be 42
someday do you want to be doctors or not
when you're 40. exactly that's the
question that's right you're going to
get there and the second thing is ask
your friends who are
physical therapist
if that was a great job when all of the
physical therapy shops got shut down
during covent every job's a great job
forever until it's not also talk to a
physical therapist who's drowning in
debt see how happy they are they're not
they're not
you can do it emily
we'll talk to you soon we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show from
nashville tennessee where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
money your life your relationships your
work your purpose everything give us a
shout triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm john dalony joined here
by ken coleman and we're taking your
calls live about just about
anything whatever's going on in your
heart and mind give us a shout triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to lori in connecticut what's
up lori how we doing
hi um thank you so much for taking my
call um
so i have so much going on right now
that i don't even know where to begin
but i guess the main purpose of my call
is my husband and i are separated and
i'm sure we're going to be you know
heading for divorce
and i'm going to be moving out of the
house we live in now to a new home
and to you i haven't you know figured
out exactly the details of that but one
thing i'm wondering should i rent or buy
a house like i hear all the time how
rents are going up and there's so many
crazy prices and it's not good to do
that
um
you know and i kind of like the idea of
buying a house and getting a little bit
more settled and that kind of thing
um so that was like one of my questions
um can you give me any advice i would
absolutely 100 not buy a house until
this divorce is six months to a year in
your rearview mirror
okay
even though you're separated do not
it's about to shake your world like a
snow globe
i've got people in my life that i'm
walking through that with they will ask
questions and you'll produce documents
from years before and text you didn't
even remember it's gonna shake
everything
make sure you wanna be where you wanna
be and how you wanna be and that you can
afford to be where you would all that
stuff i i wouldn't buy anything until
this thing has a period at the end of it
and you are on your way to healing and
then you can say okay what comes next
so rent rent
and lori renting renting is not a silly
proposition because you just mentioned
stability in the form of a home but i
will tell you that stability is safe
warm
right
uh place to lay your head down at night
you and the kids
so until everything shakes out
financially there's no way you can even
plan for that until all this stuff gets
john's absolutely right so i want you to
understand that renting is stability in
this particular situation as opposed to
trying to get into a major debt
situation with a house and everything up
in the air not to mention your emotions
that john was talking about so stability
in this case is renting it's freedom so
what's your next question
okay so then the next thing um you know
everything seems to happen at once so
i'm going to be getting laid off from my
job in like two
two months
you know this whole cover thing and you
know departments getting eliminated that
whole thing and so
i you know i'm having a real hard time
focusing on finding another job at you
know with everything else going on and
can you
help directly get started on that yeah
all right let's just start with because
again
normally i would coach someone laurie
you know and by the way i'm going to
give you my get clear career assessment
i'm going to give you from paycheck to
purpose these are resources that i want
you to take your time and go through and
normally i would say okay let's get
really clear on what you do best that's
talent what kind of work do you love
that's passion and then what results do
you want your work to create but i think
there's so much going on with you i
think it'll be really hard to be clear
so what i would focus on first is talent
alone
all right because see talent think of
talent as
your skills that you've created that you
have developed over your working life
you've got personal skills as well so
hard skills
people skills and think of those skills
plus your experience
right as assets
or
tools
to be able to do work that is valuable
and you've got that you you have talent
and you've got experience that's
transferable true or false
oh yeah no absolutely it's just more the
focus and you know the figuring out you
know peace and the uh yeah but here's
the deal
the focus is on the jobs that you have
the talent and experience to do that's
what i'm trying to help you do
i don't want you thinking about world
you know you know your dream job right
now i i normally i do that with folks
not folks that are going through major
emotional trauma
and hey i want to hop in that's the word
that akin just used as correct and lori
one of the most traumatic things a human
can go through is divorce yep one of the
most traumatic things a human can go
through is the loss of their job
one of the most traumatic things a human
can go through is the loss of their home
and you're experiencing all of this at
the same time yes so when you think i
can't focus
i it's everything spinning around that's
because your body is in fight or flight
and it is running or hiding or swinging
at everything probably a mix of both
or all three am i right
but yeah because if i'm not focused on
you know one thing i'm focused on the
other thing you know well listen
listen you don't have a choice but to
focus
on the good news is you got a two-month
head start that's right but your
full-time job
outside of your regular job right now
and being a mama and a wife who's going
through divorce is i need to get my
skills and my experience aligned to go
all right what are the jobs in hartford
connecticut or wherever you're going
what are the jobs that are posted right
now we are in the hottest job market in
the history of the united states lori i
want to encourage you
this isn't a motivational speech for me
we are at the lowest unemployment rate
in the history of
the collection of the data
right people need you lori
there are companies that will bend over
backwards for you you might get a nice
raise out of this deal but you are
focused on only one thing i have talent
and i've got experience what is that
make a list
john can speak to this it's a powerful
psychological tool to get out of your
head that's right and write it down so
so a quick example
give it back to john
write down
three to five
of your top skills i don't care if
they're people oriented or technical in
nature just write them down and then go
okay and then i want you to write down
what your most valuable experience is
think of your entire work life
this is very valuable experience and
what you've got there is is a really
rough draft
of a job description do you understand
what i'm saying
i do yeah because here's what i'm trying
to do i'm trying to take out the focus
issue and just go oh it's right there
and i gotta look for jobs that are
available right now
that match up to what i just wrote down
and then pay what i need to make and
it's discouraging if you apply for
something that you know you're qualified
for probably even overqualified for and
they'll like they don't reply it's like
oh my god another blow well
and right now your brain is so highly
attuned to rejection yeah and loss and
so every one of those is gonna not feel
like the mosquito bite it is it's gonna
feel like a punch in the nose
and
if you there's this old
developmental tool called maslow's
hierarchy when i get like you and i've
never experienced what you're going
through but when i feel like it's all
chaotic and i have to make a thousand
decisions at once and i'm struggling and
i'm hurting and i've experienced loss
all that
i know enough to know about neurology or
neuroscience that i can't do this by
myself
the greatest leveling tool you can have
the greatest thing that helps your heart
rate slow down a little bit is other
people that's it so i want you to reach
out to somebody or two people or three
people and say i need you to walk
through hell with me over the next three
months can i count on you three and oh
by the way
ten times that amount to go hey i'm
getting laid off in two months here's
what i do best here's the experience i
have will you help me find a great gig
lean on relationships that works that's
what you're doing go to relationships go
to relationships go to relationships
that's right hey we're thinking about
you so sorry
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promo
codes they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal today's question comes
from kaniah in michigan i'm in my last
year of college and worked for my
parents at their bowling center i have
been working there since high school and
i'm ready to move on my career goal is
to work in communications and
broadcasting and i found a full-time
opportunity at a local radio station
between this opportunity and my school
schedule all of my time will be booked
which would help me get out of working
at the bowling alley my parents have
said that if i live under their roof i
have to work for them so
if i were to quit
i will need to be ready to also be out
on my own
this is not a horrible thought because i
want to experience life on my own if you
were in my situation what would you do
well i'm torn with this question can i
because i got to tell you as a high
schooler i would have loved to have
worked at a bowling alley
just a little side note that has nothing
to do
with with my answer um what are you
doing can i this is a dream
i mean i would move out personally
because uh everything about this is
check box check the box check the box
check the box
and i don't like mom and dad's position
and i also call bs on them i'd call
their bluff uh that's just me but i have
issues with authority again being
transparent right um i don't believe
them but that's not about advice i just
don't believe them um i do it and uh and
if we can help you with budgeting you
know the every dollar app you need to
grab this kind of stuff now and learn
this and go okay i got a great gig
that's getting me in the world that i
want to be in
um
yeah i'd i'd go so this is the way i
west young man i tell young folks is
when you're going to make grown-up
decisions yeah you have to have
they come with grant decisions come with
grown-up consequences so i'm going to
move and i think that's the right thing
to do i think you should move out here
and it's going to come with bills that's
right and rent and
food and all the all the things and so
let's prepare like a grown up yeah right
not like a child let's get a budgeting
aspect let's get some people in our
corner and let's figure this thing out
or go get a roommate man go look around
and get a roommate or this is going to
sound bonkers this happened every year i
worked in universities seniors move back
their senior year on campus it's all
taken care of move back if you can
afford it right find a place you'll find
a place or hey pay mom and dad some rent
see how they throw that one at them make
them say no to that
this sounds like a mom and dad power
move which it's a hundred percent of
flex it's a it grinds on me a little bit
like let your scene whatever i don't
like it i don't either let's go to nick
in cincinnati what's up brother nick
hey how you guys doing today good my man
what's up
um i i know you guys time's precious so
i'll get into it uh we're here for you
man yeah what's up uh so
i got introduced to total money makeover
back at the end of 2020
um 2021 and at the time naturally i had
credit card debt car payment mortgage
2021 my finances got worse
due to
the loss of overtime i lost probably 30
to 40 percent of my income over the
course of 2021
and naturally because of that
i wasn't able to you know stay current
with credit cards
flash forward i'm i'm in a situation now
i've got a plan on
trying to get out of things i really
would like y'all's advice on you know
what you guys think of my plan
give me some criticism and maybe just
help me make a better decision
so
money number wise i got a 150 000
mortgage
i owe about 14 000 on my car and i got
about another 15 000 in credit card debt
i don't make enough right now my base
salary to keep the credit cards current
um with that being said basically all my
money every month is going towards the
house and going towards our car payments
i live in an old house so my utilities
are pretty high my mortgage is pretty
high for my income
and
i'm skimming by i get a couple hundred
dollars left every paycheck is it just
you
uh
so there's me my wife i got a
two-year-old son and my in-laws
um i'm working
hold on hold on your in-laws live with
you as well
yes are they not paying helping out with
mortgage
yeah they do they pay rent but basically
the rent money i get from them every
month
is my free
is about all the money i get you know
after everything's said and done oh okay
um is this yeah is this a
nick
you're you're giving us a math problem
here but so we'll address the math
problem
but this sounds like a
existential issue this sounds like this
is a a husband who got married and all
of a sudden has a little kid and now is
also a caretaker for her parents
this is a lot
a sound i hear a guy who's tired
yeah you know i had my dad with us too
uh up until last january um you know
that's kind of that's one of my big whys
right now as to uh you know kind of kick
me in the pants so
to get my stuff together and and i
i want to go debt free you know it's my
wife
uh you know she doesn't work right now
and
she thinks i'm a little crazy because i
listen to you guys all the time and and
talk about you guys and want to do it
but uh you know i'm trying to right now
sell the house
i'm hoping to get enough equity out of
the house to you know kind of pay off
the car pay off okay so where are you
gonna go man yeah where are you gonna
live where are you gonna go
well so that's the thing we're trying to
figure out you know we've got family
that we can stay with oh no no no no
okay can we just pause the family stuff
really fast
sure
what you lost a bunch of income what
were you making last year
uh so
for about the last four years i've made
between 80 and 90. doing what
uh i work as a warehouse supervisor in a
manufacturing facility what are you
making right now
my base salary is like 59. doing what
uh i'm i'm running a warehouse for a fda
regulated manufacturing facility so okay
i've been there for been there for about
12 years okay
could your in-laws watch the child while
your wife was working theoretically here
uh
yeah but my my wife struggles with
anxiety and depression and uh you know
that's kind of okay
that's kind of where we've been for the
last six to eight months all right so
so i'm just addressing some of the money
things we got to do because you're
trying to solve this thing with money
and there's a lot of things going on but
money is a big piece of this i don't
think you should be selling the house i
think that creates way more chaos you're
already dealing with all kinds of things
you have an income problem to add to
everything else you've listed out and my
friend you need to be making 80 to 90.
it there's no ifs ands or buts you're
already tired
you have got
to make more money
you've got to make more money because
then you can walk the baby steps out
and you've been with this group for 12
years and
great they've served their time but you
need to put those skills out on the
market and see what you can get
yeah and i've been job shopping uh you
know i haven't had a whole lot of
success with it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
you have to eat to live and if i told
you you had to kill four bucks
between now and the end of the year or
your family starves you'd find a way to
kill four deer would you or would you
not
right yeah then get after it i'm not
listen i'm not getting on you but this
is an urgency my man and you got a lot
going on in your life i get that but
right now you've got to bring in some
more income and you and the wife got to
get on the same page and go we're going
to get out of this financial mess
because you can't i'm going to i want to
encourage you 14 000 on a car and 15 000
on a credit card if you're making 90
grand and you're disciplined you can get
out of this do you understand what i'm
saying
yeah what's the car worth
uh i don't know probably about what we
owe
why don't you find out
yeah dude
you need some urgency urgency is your
friend right now
and that's why i go back you sound worn
out are you all right man
it's you know it's just it's been a you
know my wife and i aren't in a good
place because you know i kind of leaned
on her pretty heavy last year to help
out and uh yeah
it just it just didn't it didn't really
pan out and so yeah so here we are
hang on the line i'm going to send you a
copy of my new book on your past change
your future and with it's going to come
a month of free therapy for better help
and i want you to make that phone call
as soon as you get the code yes you need
to talk to somebody and i'm taking care
of the first month for you and you're
gonna make a plan and this book's gonna
help you make a plan too
but you deserve and your family deserves
more than what y'all are trying to
shuffle the deck tears on the titanic
okay you need a plan let's get some
urgency
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to page in salt lake city hey paige
what's going on
hello
how are we doing
oh good i'm just super nervous
um
we are too so we're all in this together
what's up oh good so um me and my
husband got married when i was 21 i'm 31
and we got a dave ramsey book given to
us for a wedding and we read it and we
loved it and we have spent
10 years really
doing our best to follow those those
goals and we
might we graduated college and my
husband went to graduate school across
the country and we've had babies and
we've been very tight he graduated from
graduate school and we moved to
washington state for him to do
a loan repayment program we had about
250 000 dollars in debt
and the loan repayment program was for
50 000 and over a three year period we
paid the whole thing off wow good for
you guys and um and it was a joyful
process for us we were very tight with
our money but i don't know it gave us a
lot of purpose and unity together and we
really
um we loved the process of it but a year
ago when we were um about out of debt
we were like look we're in washington
the winters are really rough we're far
away from family and
we wanted to get a job back in utah near
family and we applied and got a really
awesome job here and we came back and
something i have
kind of had in my mind my whole life
that i would do is take care of my
grandparents and um sorry i don't know i
couldn't emotional
um
and we moved back here and the home
prices are really crazy here it's one of
the worst housing markets in the country
and stuff and
we have been so conservative and a year
ago we um agreed to do i'm sorry i don't
know why i'm praying
we agreed to build a home and to put my
grandparents in the basement
my grandma is estranged from my dad and
i i grew up not having much to do with
my dad and um
so she was my only connection to my
fraternal side so i have felt this
desire to really take care of her
and all this stuff but anyway we we
looked into building so that i could
accommodate her and
we just made choices that i'm really i
really regret a lot and i i wish i could
go back a year and make them all over
again but we started building and we
agreed to build this home that was
almost a million dollars
and i kind of had this wake-up call a
few months ago when
the builder we were only supposed to
have seven seven stairs to get inside
and the builder um lifted the house way
more of the ground than we're planning
and
there's going to be 13 stairs to get
inside now and um
we
and that seems like a little thing but
it really gave us a moment to reset and
be like what are we doing like my
husband we've been conservative our
whole marriage and my husband just makes
over 200 000 and i don't think we have
any business to be getting into an
almost million dollar home
even if it's to take care of my
grandparents and
so we talked to them and we talked to
the builder and the builder has agreed
to try to sell the home which i think it
will sell just fine here but
um
you know they said we could not finish
the basement we could still have it for
about eight hundred thousand and
a lot of family members and people are
like what else are you going to do like
homes are just going crazy here and i'm
scared and i feel like the inflation is
really scary and we've been so good our
whole marriage and i part of me just
like wants my husband to quit a job and
move somewhere where the housing isn't
so expensive and i feel like we've had
this purpose
our whole marriage of like paying off
debt and being really conservative and
now that we have money and we don't have
debt i feel a little disoriented there
you go and
so so here's what i do here's what i
hear paige number one i hear a very uh
brave and
simultaneously scared woman
i also hear somebody who is someone
who's a great person who's got a great
marriage you know of shared values
and
you also care for the people in your
family and you've got some deep wounds
that resurface in
common ways and in strange ways unique
ways
and so you'll made an impulse purchase
you thought about it this was going to
be as a way to both live out the fantasy
of keeping the family together and
honoring your legacy and and fill in the
blank fill in the blank fill in the
blank and here we are and then you had
the moment of the seven stairs right
that y'all can get tattoos that just say
seven stairs on it and you said what in
the world are we doing right so here can
i free you from something
yeah
maybe you bought too big of a house
you're not a bad person
in fact your grandparents are lucky to
have you to love it's for you to be
loving them like you do
so now the question is not to revisit
and rev we've always been we've always
okay great you still are
you messed up so here we are okay so
let's put a period at the end of that
sentence there's nothing we can do to go
back and edit that we're here let's
write something new are you in for that
yeah
so paige what that means is you have an
exit the builder has agreed to sell the
house yeah essentially letting you out
of the contract am i understanding that
right
yes okay then so do it who cares what
all the family members say they don't
get a vote it's not their call
so the good news is you're debt free you
make really good money and if you've got
to rent for a little bit to reset and
figure out if hubs wants to leave salt
lake or not like this is not a crisis
you're actually okay
you haven't blown it
i think this is a do-over you get and
it's a great i mean you know it's an
almost cosmic lottery type right
it's okay celebrate this you almost made
a million dollar whoopsie-do and you got
an out and now you're like all right
[Applause]
yeah and if you if you and your husband
go rent a one bedroom apartment for six
months
and you tell your grandparents
we're unable to
support you right now we just simply
can't afford this big house
and here's the thing your family is
going to be be um
nudging you towards this house why
because you're taking ownership of all
of the stuff
of grandma granddad of all the family
drama paige is going to take care of it
so of course they want you to do this go
get a one bedroom apartment you will
have a picture in your head where you
take care of your grandparents and it
may not be the season for that right now
it may not be the housing market for
that right now it just is with that
that's that is you owning reality right
i thought i heard paige starting to say
but am i right pace
yeah i just i you know i have three kids
and i feel terrible that we've moved
them and we're renting right now and
this house that they thought we were
gonna move up to we're not moving into
now and
now maybe we're going to go rent
somewhere else for a little bit and you
know a lot of people are like you need
to hurry and buy something else because
everything's going up there you go there
you go with all these other people again
well you sure do you sure do care a lot
about other people's opinions you know
you know the greatest gift you could
give your kids
is to
take them out for dinner yeah and to sit
around the table and say hey
me and your dad almost made a huge
mistake yeah
we got so excited we love our family so
much we were gonna do this and we got
you guys all excited and everybody's
disappointed us too and you'll probably
cry because it's real close to the top
of your heart
and your husband may shed a tear and
what you're gonna do for your kids is
two important things
they're gonna get to see mom and dad say
the words i'm sorry they're gonna get to
see mom and dad have a motion they're
gonna get to see mom and dad say hey we
almost made a huge mistake so here's
what we're gonna do next and nobody
likes what happens next but this is the
world we're in and you're gonna give
them legacy gifts this is changing
family tree gifts how old are the kids
um eight six and
three eight six and three okay first of
all the three-year-old has no clue and
the six-year-old won't remember any of
this yeah and the eight-year-old's kind
of like after about two minutes of the
tears and all the nice stuff they're
checked out too
no i'm serious i i mean paige you you
and i'm having fun with this but i'm
also dead serious
they're not going to resent you over
this decision they are loved big time
are they not paige
yeah those kids don't want for much do
they paige
no stop this stop this nonsense of
everybody else telling you what you
should do your tears
and the way you and your husband have
lived your life to this point is what
matters so paige what you've created in
your head
is a picture of the way things are
supposed to be
and what you have to make peace with is
that picture's not going to work
and the challenge before you is to paint
a new picture
and it's best done with your husband
over a half day time you'll take
together
get one of these family members who
can't mind their own business to watch
the kids for half a day and you and your
husband say okay
we dodged a bullet like the matrix
what's this next picture going to look
like i have to choose what that is stay
on the line i'm going to give you a copy
of my new book own your past change your
future y'all can read it together
and it will give you a path out of this
mess we'll be right back
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is isaiah
32 8.
generous people plan to do what is
generous and they stand firm in their
generosity
the great helen keller says life is an
exciting business and it is most
exciting when it is lived for others
outstanding i love it let's go to
heather in seattle washington home of
pearl jam and the gang what's up heather
hey how are you outstanding what's going
on
so i'm just calling because i we are in
baby step 2 and our next personal debt
is an rv
hey heather
heather heather i'm sorry to interrupt i
know you're in baby step two but it also
feels like you're in a wind tunnel is
there anything you can do to help us
literally that was a joke all right yeah
it's washington
all right that's much better
guaranteed okay um
so we're in baby step two and our next
personal debt is an rv that we have and
then it's my student loans and
we use the rv as
sort of a short-term rental
last summer it made us like 10 000
just in a couple months
and then this summer we're projected to
do about 15
and that's conservative
and so i guess my question is
do we
use the proceeds for that to pay off the
rv or do we just sell the rv and not
have that
i guess as how much would you make if
you sold the rv
so we owed about 34 on it and we could
make or we could sell it for 43. oh you
owe on it sell it today yeah because go
ahead and pocket and get out of the debt
because that thing is devaluing quickly
it's not a great rental thing long term
so don't talk yourself into that or let
anybody tell you well that's an asset
that you can rent no
you have too much debt on that it'd be
one thing if you owned it clear and free
but uh i'd sell it pocket the profits
and put it towards the other debt how
much student loan do you have
70 000 yeah sell it sell it and knock it
down you'll have 60 000 to go you'll be
on your way okay
and then i guess we have rentals already
scheduled for this summer so do we just
sell at the end of the summer
or
i think you can sell it with the rentals
in mind and let them know hey we've
rented this out i don't know the
contract so if you of i don't know what
you've agreed to i don't know if this
means you're out of the rental business
forever et cetera
um i don't know what i don't know the
ins and outs and so i'm not going to
give you any insight on what to do with
the contract but it is what it is
i thought that was a sound effect from
the booth oh i thought that might be
that but it was clearly a child yeah
yeah you know what figure out your
rental contracts and if you can get out
of them i'd get out of them and sell
that's right if you can't well then
you've got contracts and you got to wait
problem with that is it devalues every
month so but yeah get out of the rv yeah
dude if you had owned it outright i
would have said hang on to it yeah sure
because it's making money yeah you don't
it's a it's forty thousand dollars just
staring you in the face let's do that
let's go to phil in minneapolis
minnesota what's up phil
hey and i know it's nice for me i know
it's minneapolis
i just always say minneapolis the grin
from kelly's face in the booth folks
i wish i had snapped a pic
not good at my words minneapolis
minneapolis what's up phil
hey guys thank you so much for taking
the call of course ma'am
so here's here's my question so um yeah
me and my wife are kind of fortunate we
have you know we have a great life here
we're destiny we make blue their money
but um so through the pandemic i think
we've been
sort of rethinking some priorities in
life um
uh so my wife wants to have um you don't
have any children and she wants to have
a kid next year
and then when she does that she wants to
sort of go
to sort of work a part-time
role
and i also kind of want to switch
careers
and what i would ideally like to do is
take a few years and try and build some
video games uh but that's a really kind
of high risk um
field uh you could sort of have multiple
years where you make no money at all
um so what i'm trying to figure out is
you know my current plan is to sort of
wait over 55 and then just sort of
quote-unquote retire early and then try
and do this build a video game while my
wife
kind of continues to work part-time um
i kind of want to know if you all think
that's a
reasonable idea do you think i can do it
sooner i'm going to jump into one thing
and i'm going to hand this off to kid
okay phil
the big thing is that
is setting off my alarms here
is you said
my wife decided she wants to have a baby
so she's going to have one next year
that should be a wee decision yeah as if
you're not involved
no it is it is almost certainly a we
decision you should participate in that
and both
you misunderstood that i did so you're
in on this
yes absolutely i'm 100 and on this i i
did
i didn't say the word we because the
video game thing was just just me okay
so i'll turn over to ken about the jobs
well and i would also just say this too
i appreciate the uh the spirit of the
question but guess what stacey and i
struggled for years and years and years
to get pregnant so i just want to kind
of i don't i don't wish that on anyone
oh we did too but it's not a simple
thing as well we want to have one next
year so well that's going to happen well
we don't know that and i so i just i
want to put this out there to go because
it does have context to my to my
suggestion
my suggestion is it's a combination of
of the scenarios you gave us
i absolutely do not like you leaving
your very stable career right now that
has afforded you the ability to be
debt-free and all the other great things
to
go after video game design right now
that is very risky your words not mine
and i don't like that risk it's an
unnecessary risk
i'm a fan of risk but i'm a fan of an
adjective in front of it called
mitigated i like mitigated risk meaning
we plan for the absolute worst we know
what the worst is but we have a plan for
that so it's kind of like it's kind of
like my dad teaching me to ride the bike
my dad taught me he was brilliant
johnny taught me to ride on a flat
grassy patch behind her house that's
mitigated risk my dad's going the kid's
going to wreck the bike
the risk is high that he's going to
wreck but i'm going to mitigate it by
he's going to
wreck on the grass and so he's not going
to stick the sheets for two weeks
taught me on the highway yeah your dad's
is not an evil person right it's
terrible all right so uh phil here's my
point what could you do
nights and weekends
even with a newborn baby i'm just
thinking what could you do to progress
towards the dream
of full-time video game design why do we
have to wait till we're 55 if we do it
smart on the side
don't over commit financially we piddle
around we get really good at one thing
uh do you understand what i'm asking
like what's the part-time
uh
kind of crawl
walk
well before we run and by the time 55
we've learned a lot of things because
we've tried some things we didn't risk
much that's kind of what i'd like to see
and then i yeah i love the idea of 55
going after full time because you're
retired now it's like there's little
risk at all does that make sense yeah
that
that is that is a fair point i guess i
guess the only sort of thought was again
what you just said which is you know if
we have a child it's kind of
from what i hear it's gonna be really
hard uh and and uh uh sure
i don't know that i'm gonna have a lot
of because my job is fairly stressful so
i think you won't see that first of all
having a child is the hardest thing
you'll ever do okay john and i can tell
you that
secondly um i
had three children under the age of
three
ran my own small business and pursued
broadcasting
it's possible you can figure it out
it is not one of these oh there's no way
i'd have time ken how would i find the
time trust me you can find the time
you are you are a excellent risk
mitigator aren't you
uh well i mean
oh i don't know if you were talking to
me
yeah you are good at you're good at
surveying the landscape and finding
where the minds might be and you're good
at avoiding that aren't you
oh absolutely i mean the fact that we're
dead for you i mean i would say we're
allergic to that like
right like we live well within our means
i guess the 55 thing was you know we
was just like me thinking
i know we will be financially completely
stable at that point and then there'd be
like no risks but you've boxed yourself
into an either or it's either financial
risk and security when i'm 55 or i quit
everything and swan dive off the top of
a building with a baby on the way right
and what we're telling you is there's a
thousand options in between a and z
right
that's a fair point there's the
part-time option there's the um there's
the
mr beast grinding it out for year after
year after year after year after year
figuring it out and being tired and
that's just part of it of being of
somebody who's got a dream right there's
all these different parts to it and
components to it but you can make it
happen don't box yourself into a well if
this happens then i can only do it like
that's not how that works man chase it
chase it chase it phil hey everybody
this has been the ramsay show live well
be kind work hard and be
generous we will see you soon on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you